hi I'm Nick Gillespie and i'm with matt
welch my co-author of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America and my
long-standing comrade at Reason magazine
reason calm reason TV dbag sandwich ask
the next question via Twitter for ask a
libertarian day who were your biggest
influences in writing your book my
biggest influences in general in writing
are probably Bill James the Great's
counterintuitive baseball writer václav
havel dissident turned president turned
old guy hunter s thompson and martin
luther king a lot of people the four of
whom were very interested in the notion
of truth and following truth and if you
cut away all the obfuscating BS in life
he will reach a higher understanding and
that can have a powerful influence on
things but in terms of the book itself
I'm honey no for better for worse very
influenced by a nickel SPI he
articulated a vision in the magazine in
the last 10 years with such essays as
the culture boom which is a great
classic that talked about our modern
world where culture proliferate sand
people own the means of production just
how fun that is and how it's changing
the way we approach different things and
he created a political magazine which
attracted the likes of me would you know
people who follow politics but kind of
hate politics and and it's a sensibility
that I think is Asif used in the book
well thank you i appreciate that oh
that's and it's a surprise to me but for
me the long time long term influences
include people like Leslie Fiedler who I
had the opportunity to work with briefly
at Buffalo when I was pursuing a PhD
Leslie Fiedler is a great poet is the
great post-war literary and cultural
critic of America I think in his vision
of a world that is just kournikova kin
its variety and greatness and interest
it really still makes me excited to
think about the world and exploring and
what's going on there more specifically
at reason Virginia postural who is my
predecessor as editor
helped me so much in terms of being a
journalist and a thinker and kind of
working teasing out the implications of
my ideas and then specifically with the
book I have to say that this is a
summary statement really have a lot of
the stuff that we've been doing at the
magazine over the past decade I think
but in in the past five years or so
veronique do regime who is a
contributing editor to reason and who is
a contributor to my life and a
collaborator both in stories and in
other ways is the person who gave me the
chops to really start thinking about
fiscal policy and about government
spending from an economic point of view
that makes sense and on a personal note
she is the person who straighten my life
out and made it possible for me really
to be standing here and hopefully
standing even taller 10 years from now
you